i guess as barisma money ran out hunter
biden is apparently an
artist now he's selling his abstract
works for as much as
half a million dollars per painting so
who's buying this crap
hunter's art dealer says sales are
confidential which is raising the
question once again of whether the first
son
is selling access greg gutfeld
influence peddling well he went from one
scam to another but this one's better
because
before he was the guy that was having to
explain why he didn't deserve six
figures a month for a job
in which he wasn't qualified for now
he's gonna have to try to explain
why he doesn't deserve six figures for
painting things that look like [ __ ]
vomit i don't know if you've seen the
pictures
but it's easy to be an imposter in this
art world because they're all imposters
aren't they it's like
no one knows art and they play off
everybody's insecurities so nobody
really will say
that's not art no just say oh that's
pretty good and maybe it's for influence
but even he's in on the joke
because he paints with a straw i love
that and once
and what is he known for you know he
used to snort blow with a straw
now he uses uses to blow paint that's
like o.j simpson
deciding to go to chef school and using
the same knives
[Laughter]
i would i measured it in art history you
did oh no wonder
yes and i know
[Laughter]
and i know that there are a lot of
stupid rich people who who want to buy
some access
or smart rich people that buy some
access so you could have a russian
billionaire
hand the biden family a half a million
dollars and the biden family just gives
the guy a watercolor back
and we're not supposed to say wait a
second the media has no clue what's
going on here that would be like
don jr taking up sculpting and so he
just whittles a little spear you know
he's a hunter
he whittles the spear and then so some
russian gives him a half a million and
the media is going to say oh that sounds
like it's a straight deal
of course not they're violating every
spirit of the law
i mean what's this it's got to be
illegal to do this right
it has to be illegal well i'm sure the
fbi would be interested in looking into
it given that they're invested into
investigating his uh
taxes and other things so um harold you
were sitting in front of uh
andy warhol mal painting at one time and
you didn't know it was andy warhol
so what do you think of as a amateur
what do you think of his art look i i
don't i don't buy a lot of art
um but but i don't know no but i don't
begrudge a guy
uh for trying to make a living and if if
he's if it turns out there's something
that's not above board here i'm certain
they'll find out and based on your
comments should i say someone's probably
gonna look into it uh this this
afternoon but
i don't i don't begrudge a guy maybe
hunter and and former president bush may
come together and do some do some hard
work together
yeah uh yeah i don't think bush is
selling it to
saudi billionaires though but we don't
know who he's selling
exactly because they won't tell you if
you sold anything
oh he's going to sell trust me i just
will see i think about like this
who in their right mind would go and pay
and by the way these numbers are just
total bs because they just make them up
six numbers
right exactly but who would actually go
and even spend
five thousand dollars on one of these
paintings and put it in their fourier
and then people come over and they're
like look at my biden
look at my laughed out of town i didn't
think some of the paintings were that
bad
i have to say and i like when i was a
kid i used to love doing that blow art
thing i don't know if i was that good
but
i i kind of like it is that what you
call it in the art world and the art
world
i mean there's a lot of shady stuff that
goes on in the art world
it's a lot it's a place to hide a lot of
money yes and so that's why this is
maybe a lot of brushes with the law oh
very
good let's just end it right there yes
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else